a controversial new law in Arizona
spells out what happens to frozen
embryos when a couple gets divorced the
state law took effect on July 1st
it requires courts to give embryos to
the spouse who plans to use them to have
a baby supporters of the law say it will
protect a partner's right to his or her
embryos opponents say it could force
people to become parents against their
will
Tony de copal has a story of one ex
couple at the center of this fight Tony
really interesting story heritable
debate really fascinating good morning
everybody more and more couples are
deciding to freeze their embryos in
hopes of one day becoming parents the
Department of Health and Human Services
says there are more than 600,000 frozen
embryos in the US but what happens when
these couples divorced the legal dispute
over who can use those embryos has
become increasingly complex I wanted to
at one day become a mom Ruby tour has
always wanted kids so when she was
diagnosed with breast cancer in 2014 she
decided to undergo in-vitro
fertilization I wasn't sure what was
going to happen in my future
and so I wanted to ensure that I had
that option doctors used her eggs and
her then-fiance sperm to form seven
embryos but by the time she was
medically cleared to try to get pregnant
they were divorcing and he no longer
wanted children a judge ruled that
Torres had no right to use the embryos I
was disappointed I was angry there's a
potential for children to be born that
will have my DNA and they will never I
will never hold them I will never see
them in similar cases across the country
courts often rule in favor of the person
who does not want the embryos used but a
new Arizona state law would change that
the legislation gives custody of the
embryos to the spouse who intends to
allow them to develop to birth CBS News
legal analyst Rickey claiming most
courts that have looked at the situation
of embryos have decided that they will
only bring the embryos to term if both
sides mutually consent
currently in Arizona under this
legislation you can compel someone to
have a child they do not want to have
Claudia work represents Tauruses
ex-husband John Tyrell she says the law
could have devastating consequences for
people like her client you're hoping to
move on and you've got an ex who is
essentially asking for you to impregnate
them and have this lingering lifelong
tie with them the new law says the
spouse that is not awarded the embryos
has no parental responsibilities and no
right obligation or interest with
respect to the child
meaning they wouldn't be forced to pay
child support still work says there are
other costs in becoming a parent even if
the gloss states that they're not a
legal parent there's still an emotional
parent it's virtually impossible to
separate themselves from the fact that
their ex had a child that is
biologically there's some abortion
rights advocates also have concerns the
law is aimed at establishing the
personhood of unborn embryos which they
say could have consequences for women's
reproductive rights and with conflicting
rulings around the country legal experts
say this issue could go all the way to
the Supreme Court now if you're
wondering the law cannot be applied
retroactively Li and therefore it
shouldn't directly effect the Torres
case which we featured that is under
appeal so the judge will decide well
that situation that seems together if
you go into the in vitro knowing that
this could be a possible consequence
that seems a lot different than if it
changes while you're in the middle no
the law says that the the the the father
the would be father wouldn't have to pay
child support has no obligation but no
law and no judge can change the fact
that a child will come knocking at some
point yeah there are obligations to
becoming a parent but it could be her
only chance to I'm saying you know I
might not want your crusty butt but I do
want my baby it's true and so why
couldn't they be something that the
parent signs that you will have no
financial responsibility or obligation
to this child what about the emotional
responsibility no I
it's tough you see both sides really in
this story Tony that was break there are
two sides I guess
I feel for the woman I feel for both
parties